hey what's up guys welcome to this video
tutorial what I want to do is basically
talk you through my rapid prototyping
process within web flow so what I'm
going to do is just show you how I would
take a concept in this case it's a
concept for a dashboard that I've just
put together in balsamic it's not a
completely thought-out concept or
completely thought out product the idea
is just to create a couple of screens so
a kind of a dashboard screen and then
kind of a secondary page and then log in
and then just show you my prototyping
process of how I would get this into web
flow get it down as a wireframe and
that's what we're gonna look at in the
first video and then the second video
we're gonna look at the how it could
actually bring some interactivity if we
wanted to build out and make it into an
interactive prototype as well and we're
really just going to focus on things
like the flows and communicating the
concept as a kind of an initial
prototype that we may show our client or
stakeholders so let's go ahead and jump
into web flow right so let's create a
login page let's list out all the
different pages first just so we know
where we are in terms of structure and
hierarchy so let's duplicate this and we
are going to have a dashboard page
freelances and company page
freelancers companies jobs reports and
settings so I mean I'm thinking this is
a never didn't explain it earlier but
this is kind of its it's like a
freelance platform it's like you sign in
you find jobs you connect with other
freelancers you connect with other
companies you pitch for jobs you earn
money a little bit like something like
up work or something like that just a
loose concept for a kind of a community
of freelancers and a community of people
that could work together
[Music]
okay so companies jobs reports and
settings
jobs reports we're not gonna build out
everything one of these pages we're just
gonna focus on a couple okay so let's
grab a section sorry section let's just
call this because this is just how I
approach things I'm gonna call it sexual
wide and that's like the widest part of
the page then within that I'm going to
have a container that sits within that
and I'm gonna call it section inner and
this is going to be like a central
column a central container on the
website and it's going to be everything
that aligns it in the middle mmm
right let's bring that form into that
okay let's bring our form into that but
first what we want to do is set the
width so we're going to say width 100%
which means that the container takes up
the full width of its parent container
but then we want to set a max width on
it because its parent container
currently takes up the full width of the
screen and we don't want this central
column to take up the full width of the
screen so max width of 1200 pixels and
what that basically means is that if the
parent container is over 1200 pixels
this central container will sit nicely
in the middle of the screen and if it's
less than it will scale to the full
width of the device which is kind of how
we want it to work right
let's call this login form again we're
just gonna move through quickly it's
this is about prototyping stuff quickly
getting ideas out down on the page and
then BM to like present them to people
and show them to people but we also want
this logging forms not stretch this full
width because it's quite long so let's
say that's 500 pixels and let's also
center align that but we are going with
a login form but we want our login form
to sit slap-bang in the middle of the
page so we're actually going to use
flexbox I'm gonna sell this login form
block right like that and the login form
block we wanna set the width 100% the
height 100 VH which is full full height
of the the parent container but then we
want to bounce over and use flexbox use
flexbox and we're gonna say that the
content is horizontally and vertically
aligned so we're saying login form block
the contents horizontally and vertically
aligned which means that this sits
nicely in the center of the page so
we've got a login form there got a login
form block which we're applying the
flexbox properties to which allow it's
in the middle of the page we've got that
within a section inner which is keeping
everything nicely centered in the page
and then we've got it wrapped up in this
section wide and and that might not be
so obvious why we have a section wide
here but further down the line all it
allows you to do is manipulate the the
full kind of background of the page so
if you wanted to have like a full width
and a full height background but then
within that you wanted content that was
Center aligned and not full width or
full height
then it just gives you more option to
kind of manipulate it but we don't want
to worry too much about that in a minute
because we just want to build out like
kind of prototype so that's how she just
get rid of that next thing we want to do
is add a little bit of a header so we
just want to add like a top navigation
strip and we just want to add it like a
potential logo so notice as well because
we're prototyping we're not styling
anything we're just keeping everything
default we want to keep things in Arial
because it's nice and boring it's nice
and plain and the point is not to
actually approach the design of the
minute it's just to think purely about
content layout content structure and
hierarchy you know the user flows and
different things like that and and when
we're presenting a prototype we just
want people to be able to use it and
experience it and move through it and
analyze it from that perspective rather
than focusing too much on how the design
works but what we do want to do is
because it's web focuses our form this
is the first page they land on we want
to redirect them to a particular page so
I'm actually going to just use a little
hack here and rather than having a form
button I'm just going to have a normal
button and we're going to call this so
let's just make this consistent with the
wireframe so we've got email password
and then we can change our placeholder
text so it's just your name it's a bit
more succinct your email so let's say
that these required because when we demo
it to someone or when we test on it we
can actually get people to input their
details and it feels a bit more like the
real product let's change the button
text here in yes oh sorry going back to
the button so let's use this to redirect
to our first page so then that creates
the impression that you land on the
login screen you enter your details you
click to login and it takes you to our
first page so it would be something like
this so let's make that required
cool and then let's redirect to the
dashboard so email password whatever
click login and then it goes to our
dashboard so that's kind of emulating
that user flow which is quite nice the
other thing you want to do is add in a
header here that's cool this well that's
been the middle as well let's go as the
login header let's call this login I
said a little kind of margin to that oh
not that much something like that maybe
that's too much login cool ok you know
what as well let's like let's give this
a little bit of interest so let's make
this gray and then what we're gonna do
is break this out on a box so we're
gonna have a login form and then I've
got a nice white background
we're gonna add a bit of padding so I'm
gonna say 40 pixels might be a bit too
much I think that's cool but we've just
got a bit too much there because this
has got padding on it
there we go it's like a login box and a
login screen for the first screen of the
prototype and we want to add in a header
here so it's grab a div and let's say
wired right let's give that a background
color as well okay let's set that width
with a hundred percent it's it's already
I kind of percent anyway in a sense now
let's give that an inner container so we
can centralize the contents let's call
this header in a hundred percent max
1200 pixels and again because you're on
a central centralizer you need auto now
that's disappeared because because
there's no contents what it's
automatically going to do is just fold
up to nothing because it the height of
it expands to fill the content so
because there is no contents it goes to
nothing just so we can see if we're
going to give it a height at 50 pixels
but actually what we want to do is
because of the nature of this dashboard
we don't really want this header Center
aligned so we're actually just going to
call this logo block
I'm going to say width 200 pixels 50
this is literally this is the
placeholder for a logo okay and again
this is this is the thing with
wireframes it's just or and prototypes
it's just all about blocks it's thinking
in terms of blocks it's not going into
too much detail it's just you know
bringing stuff together on the page this
goes here this goes there called um
let's move on to the next page you know
there's that very kind of quick
successive way of prototyping things and
bringing things together you know think
about the detail and everything like
that the kind of more refined UI stage
head wide so what we want is a bit of
padding because we don't want this logo
to sit right up against the head of that
okay so let's start looking at the the
main dashboard page bringing this into a
wireframe so we've got a sort of a tight
a heading of the page we've got a header
at the top we've got some kind of
figures that we've pulled out these
could be nicely animated or have ads and
then some kind of visually interest to
the page and we've got a list of new
jobs within the platform and new
freelancers that join the platform as
well so to look at how we can build that
out so this is an interesting kind of
design challenge here we want to kind of
create this sidebar that that sticks to
the left of the page we want to create
this header as well and then we want to
also keep all of this stuff in the
center of the page too so let's have a
think about how we could do that I've
done this before on a couple of projects
so we are going to grab our header a
wide
dump this into here that's also grab
section this section wide so this is the
thing it's about kind of creating
reusable elements you know so your
section wired is consistently it's
always got a grey background it's always
the full-width page and you know that
you can build on that as like a canvas
with the rest of your content sexually
inert so let's not worry about that for
a minute so we've got a section wide
what we also want to do is that what's
going on there
why that's happening oh I know why
because alright cool okay so don't worry
about that for a minute
what we want to do is we want to kind of
want to figure out how we can build this
navbar on the left and then this content
section on the right so what we're going
to do is we're going to create a
container we're going to fix it to the
left then we're going to create a wider
container and we're going to move the
contents of that over to the right so it
misses the sidebar on the left and
brings it into the middle of the screen
and that probably didn't make much sense
but I'll show you what we're gonna do so
section wide so let's call this section
left call this next bit section right
we're gonna say section left hi hundred
percent
let's give it a fixed-width right
because we don't want it to be fixed so
if we have like 200 pixels
[Music]
let's give it a background can't see
anything at the minute in fact let's
give it an absolute height just so we
can be sure of where it is okay it's a
section left let's fix that so it's
absolute
let's get sexual right and okay just so
you can see what I'm doing date section
left it's gonna be like a red color
alright section right let's make that
blue I'm just gonna give it a high at
500 pixels as well then what we want to
happen is we've done that to be Auto we
can fix that on the learning page so we
you kind of see here we've got you know
we've got our head up we've got this
sidebar and we've got this section right
but then what we want to do is you want
to have an inner section in this section
right so we can actually put some
content in it
I call that section in a write and what
we want to do then is you want to offset
that by the width of this on the left so
this is 200 pixels alright so let's get
that and let's bring a margin of let's
say 240 pixels right okay right if I
said that sounded VH if I said that to
100% it's gonna go to there and set that
to 100 percent as well I can't I might
have to tweak this in a mix I don't know
if these percentages are gonna work
properly but do you see how this is
coming together so section left let's
turn that into something that's maybe a
bit darker this section right let's get
rid of that so you see so now we have
right the makings of a dashboard so
column on the Left heading at the top
and content area on the right let's
lighten this up a little bit
again when you're making prototypes so
gonna be grayscale but you want to think
about the different levels or of the
content so stuff that's at the
background you know if you want to make
that go to the background yeah it should
be kind of lighter it should be less
heavy if you want to bring stuff to the
foreground make it darker make it more
heavy you know and think about it's
really you know it's fifty shades of
gray basically okay so what we want to
do now is just quickly build our RM like
a list so we're gonna call this sidebar
nav list alright no bullets gonna call
this sidebar list item
okay and we're gonna add some what we
want to do is we want to make these like
buttons right so let's add some link
blocks in there so that means the whole
the whole thing is going to be clickable
so as a sidebar link block I'll show you
how that's going to work
right and then we want to add some text
so let's call this the sidebar text link
let's call this dashboard so let's get
all our content in then we can style it
up really easily in web play so with
dashboard freelancers companies and jobs
so T 3 dashboard freelancers companies
companies jobs reports and settings
settings cool so let's give so we're
kind of making these into big clickable
blocks so let's give that full width
let's add some padding we've got some
padding between the more then let's add
like a border like a divider just to
show that they're separate blocks just
make that a bit more subtle something
like that and then let's get rid of no
let's keep I mean this is a prototype so
let's keep these on the line we want to
show that they're links but what it
means is that we've now got sort of
clickable buttons here so if I click on
each of those I would go to the relevant
page which is pretty cool now what we
might do just to show that this is a
selected state is webflow has a like a
current link which should should allow
me to say that the link of the page that
I'm selected on appears differently I'm
not seeing that I think it's because I'm
not yeah so I'm not actually
so let's link these up so we want to go
freelancers as I say I'm not building
out every page but I'm just showing you
how to like rapidly create a simple
prototype you know using this approach
and workflow freelancers dashboard so
yeah you see there it says current so
this then says that the current page
we're actually able to style it so that
what's currently selected can appear a
bit differently so let's just say let's
have that pyramid darker and I think we
could change the text color as well
let's just leave that you know that's
fine it just shows us we're on that page
so there we go if we click on that well
we don't have the navigation on that
page but you'll see it if we did
okay cool so we get in there so we've
got our navigation made let's look at
top level navigation so we just want to
bring in this kind of it's like a
drop-down normally on a dashboard you
have a link at the top right that lets
you access things like your account and
your settings and it's like a kind of a
my profile link so we can just add that
in really easily this is already floated
so we want to float this to the left
this logo and then we just want to use
like a simple drop down like a select
app that she has to be in a form which
is fine
so let's use this drop down this one's
pretty cool right so that's the standard
kind of web flow drop-down so this cool
web profile drop down and let's give it
a bit of a border so it kind of stands
off the white background and let's call
this normally on a dashboard you kind of
have like you have the person's name if
you're logged in and then you maybe have
a little picture of them then you could
access different elements from that
drop-down so let's just
and this flight this to the right okay
we've got our padding here so it doesn't
sit right in the right right let's just
publish that okay cool and we can you
know we can access other parts of the
prototype using those potential links so
I don't know why this is red now it's
because it's gone red for some weird
reason so let's just add in a couple of
other options there so if we go to the
drop down list and we show that we can
then actually choose the options here so
we could have my account settings and
again if you're building out you know
the whole prototype then you could link
this up off to all the other individual
parts of the the dashboard and the
prototype you can do a lot with it but
just for the purposes of this video
we're just gonna kind of I'm not gonna
actually link all that up today so we've
got this we've got a sort of a page
title and then we've got this content
here that we're gonna add in so let's go
to our section you know right and what
we want to do is add in a heading I'm
going to make this an h1 because it's
the main heading of the page so in the
coolest like dashboard h1 let's make it
32 let's call this overview as per the
wireframe there let's add a bit of
padding to this main kind of
intersection so this is section in a
riot is this kind of centralized column
that sits on the right-hand side of the
dashboard sorry on the navigation and
we're just going to add some padding in
there so let's add in something about 20
pixels padding
and there's definitely going to be a few
things that we can we need to kind of
like tweak tweak and just kind of smooth
over with the prototype and definitely
with the response of stuff we can look
at that too but we're just going to
focus it kind of getting the content in
and just kind of getting something
together tangible for the minute so
we've got these three boxes which are
kind of like call-out boxes that they're
sort of notifications telling the user
how much they've earned how many new
jobs are within the platform and how
many new freelancers have joined the
platform so to do that we're going to
choose a some columns and we're gonna
call this three collar row then we're
gonna choose how many columns we're
gonna have so we're gonna have three and
then just so we can kind of apply some
styling to the individual columns if you
wanted to some a I always do I just I
kind of get them individual classes free
and we want to actually bring that in
that central container there hmm
okay so let's call this info box and
this little thing here is going to be
like an icon or some sort of image or
some sort of illustration that just goes
with the the data but again it's it's a
prototype so we're just going to keep
this keep it simple keep it blocky
let's just give that a fixed width and a
fixed height so let's give out a box a
background color let's give this some
pattern so it's not all so close to the
edges 20 20 20 I'm kind of just working
in multiples of 20 sometimes how I like
to do things it's no hard and fast rule
around that I just I like to keep things
consistent and say you know let's work
in multiples of 20 or 30 or whatever we
think is best for the project okay so so
it doesn't actually need to be a heading
so let's call this get a text block
let's call that an info number large
again just thinking of things quickly
getting the content in you know it's
it's a kind of an early stage prototype
it doesn't you don't need to spend a
ages thinking about things give it a bit
of impact make it bold as well let's
make it bold so what we want to do is
show you one okay so we've got that I
mean want to give this a little bit of
text as well it's cause in the faux
detail right this month okay so what we
want to do now is bring this figure and
this little piece of text kind of in
line with the icon so if we floated this
to the left it's like that to the left
and then we float that to the left it
doesn't really work so what we what we
kind of want to do I think is put them
in we want to put them in separate
containers I think that's the best way
to do it so let's call this info block
left
mm okay I'm gonna put the icon in there
and it's a info block left it's 50
pixels and we're gonna keep the Hyatt
standard sorry Auto let's call this info
block right so then this is going to be
the the the opposite container that
we're going to float right or even yeah
we're gonna float it left
so in for left let's plate that left
let's not float this so that this now
breaks out onto there so that's not
floated this also isn't floated but we
want to float the wrapper to the left
perfect now let's add some bit of margin
to the bottom there and then let's also
add a bit of margin here
cool okay so that is line-height there
mmm okay cool
maybe we can just could that be a little
icon like a circle or something yes make
it like a circle mm-hmm just so it's a
bit more interesting it's pretty much it
yeah cool so we've got so let's just
copy and paste that then let's just
change the content got 57 new jobs 18
new freelancers and there's this central
column is obviously really wired and
we're gonna sort this out shortly so
it's kind of
stretching the whole width we can sort
that out so look we've got our flow kind
of setup login let's enter our details
hi password something login bang we're
into our dashboard and we haven't got
the other pages set up here now let's
work on these two columns here so same
thing again hmm
let's use a two two column layout and
that's close to call right two columns
let's drag this down let's just call
this call left
call riot again don't necessarily have
to give these classes but I just it's
like a habit just if we wanted to use
the style one of these columns
specifically then we we can do that so
let's call this new job block add a bit
of padding as well for here but also
yeah so we don't you know we might use
three column row again that's like a
reusable element so we don't want to
necessarily add a margin to the bottom
of that because if we're using it
elsewhere it might affect that layout so
let's give this so let's wrap that in
something and then let's refer to that
thing that we've wrapped in specifically
so let's call this info block okay we
can add a margin to the bottom of that
and then for this let's call it
let's call this new new info block let's
call it a notification block cool right
new job block let's give this background
color because again we we want it to be
like a kind of a block or a card that's
sitting on the page let's also give this
a bit of padding and the other thing was
in web flow by default the columns have
like they have their own kind of padding
within them so they have a padding of 10
pixels left and right and what that
means is you can kind of get this thing
where it doesn't really match up with
that with the border of the parent
container so what I often do is just I
whack a minus on this so I say minus 10
well it's 10 and that kind of balances
stuff out
okay so that's how about heading here
let's have this as a heading two right
let's say dashboard heading 2 for a
dashboard h2 and let's think about
hierarchy so maybe that could be a bit
bigger maybe that's 48 let's bring this
down to something like 32 there's a bit
more of a contrast in the hierarchy
there I've got new jobs let's give this
card some some padding cool let's just
take the margin off of that and then we
want to create these kind of list items
so we can do that pretty easily using
the list element let's grab a list and
let's just call it a new job list list
let's grab a list item let's call it a
new job item
again you know moving quickly not
thinking too much about stuff just sort
of getting getting the idea down and
getting something tangible down and
again we've got the same thing here you
know we want an image on the left and
then we want to flight this text to the
right so let's do the same thing that we
did above let's call this new job left
duplicate that right let's see how this
will work in there we can rename it
let's call this new job icon maybe this
could be like if it was a job from a
company it could be a logo or it could
be an image or you know it could even
just be a sort of a generic platform
icon depending on the the ship depending
on the context this job laughter cool
just get rid of that and called a new
job
fifty-fifty with that so so a similar
kind of gray all we want to do and
that's in new job
left so let's float that to the left new
job right let's add some text in let's
call this new job new job title let's
make it Arial bold again I think that's
this earlier but keep you know if you're
making a prototype keep your text simple
don't worry about fancy fonts or
anything like that just to keep it
simple keep it readable use Arial it's a
bit boring but that's kind of the point
right
so let's float this to the right and
then let's add a little margin on the
left so it pushes that right container
away then we want to add a little
description
let's grab some text and let's call this
new job description
rip zoom
lovely stuff all right cool
and then the other thing we want to do
so a new job item let's get rid of these
list items so we can just duplicate this
one Isis had a margins that I sorry
a divider to the bottom there so he know
that it's something and that's also
that's a had a bit of padding margin
there and then let's push this away as
well so let's um it's a bit of a kind of
a bottom margin on that you see and then
a free yeah if we wanted to okay
so sub six
and then actually sorry incident on this
had some pattern so the new job list
item has padding 20 pixels at the bottom
on the top there you go we could also do
what we could also do is um maybe we
could add like a divider to that that's
probably not necessary okay cool so it's
coming together right and then we kind
of just want to we kind of just want to
repeat the same thing here so it's sort
of making me think do we need to do we
need to kind of rename all these classes
like like what I'm trying to say is do
we need to have a block for new jobs and
a block for new you freelancers or can
we just use the same kind of classes for
that and just be a bit more generic and
I think we can and I think what we can
do is we could say look we can use the
rename function and you can say new job
new item block right
it's more of a generic item block
dashboard h2 is fine let's call this
rename let's call this new item title
right so it's just a bit more generic in
the way that we're referring to it but
it means that we don't have to like re
like we don't have to create another
kind of element and give it give it a
load of new classes or anything like
that you write description new item icon
alright cuz it's all the same thing
right it's just new items on the
homepage so let's grab this let's put it
in this column let's just change this
title okay
and there we pretty much have it this is
kind of cool right
obviously again this is going off the
edge of the page we can sort that out
but as you can see you know the
prototype is coming together actually
what we also might want to do and we're
not gonna go there just in a minute but
what we also might want to do is make
this whole block like clickable so if we
wanted to link through from the from
this list to to the actual item that
we're talking about then we could do
that right so 1 2 3 4 5 6 and then we
could say if we actually had like a a
page that had the job type the job on it
then we could link to that but um we're
not we're not there just at the minute
okay and then maybe we don't want this
to all be in blue because it's not like
a primary link so we want to just kind
of change our text color a little bit
there but sorry I'm going around in
circles here we need to give the link of
class to be able to do that
okay
where are we item let's call it item
link okay it's just got a class that
means every other class of item link
will be styled this way oh why is it
okay new job item ok cool new job list
okay I don't know what happened there I
thought I rename that item list let's
just call it new item all right spell it
right okay it's a new item I see three
four six cool new item block put it in
there again change it
this is adding a name let's just say
freelancer name right it's probably the
long way of doing it but it
sorry job title okay now it's always
better to use you know I'm setting a bad
example here it's it's always way better
to use real content in a wireframe or a
prototype because then you're actually
you're designing for the content you
have but I am just kind of using these
generic names for the purpose of this
prototype okay so new jobs new
freelancers and if you want we can click
and then that would go to the actual
single page if we have that set up we
don't have that in a minute so that's
that's basically the home page so or the
dashboard rather so we've got we've got
our overview we've got our figures these
could be you know some interesting
figures that counted up when you first
learned it on the page just to provide
like a bit of visual interest we could
have like some charts or graphs or
something like that there that we've
just got a list of new jobs within the
platform and new freelancers and you
could click on one of these and that
would take you through to the specific
page for that item that you clicked on
and we've also kind of got this just
drop down and and this is what I like
about web flow compared to like
prototyping in static software you know
like sketch or something there's a lot
you can do is sketch but you know to
just get something like in the browser
you know get it kind of responding and
being able to interact with it and
create these kind of actual interactions
and link up screens and it's just
nothing really beats it for that it does
have its drawbacks it's not like you can
you know whereas in sketch you can
design and a slightly more freehand way
without thinking of the HTML output you
can do that which is a bit
Limited in webflow but you know it's
horses for courses and it really depends
on you know the project itself from and
what you're looking is kind of achieved
and Andy so let's build out this page
real quick so let's jump to the
freelancers page we have nothing there
but let's grab this and we're just going
to use exactly the same layout and setup
and they grab our header we're going to
put that on the freelancers page I'm
gonna grab a section wide here again
it's just you know super simple copy and
paste drop stuff him I'm gonna call this
freelancers and we're gonna get rid of
this bit and this bit I'm going to keep
the same section inner and then we're
gonna grab some Camtasia open there then
we're gonna grab some three columns and
we're gonna grab put them in here we're
gonna do is say freak alright again
change that
cool one as actually I probably could
have made my life easier by keeping the
other one that was there but too late
now okay so call free then what we're
gonna do is grab a div and we're gonna
call this just gonna call it freelance
hard let's call this directory card
right because it could be a freelancer
it could be a business it could be a
project again it's all to do with the
kind of site architecture and how we're
gonna sort of approach things and lay
things out on the different classes and
names have gonna give two things some it
would probably consider it more detail
if this was a real project that's but
you know just for the purposes of this
video I'm kind of storming through it a
bit so let's get a little block here
let's call this directory image
look at that 50 by 50 now we want that
to appear in the middle so set a margin
of auto let's give our card a little
background let's make it white just make
the image gray turn that into a little
circle using border radius and again
give this card some padding so we've got
a nice amount of padding on it okay and
let's call this directory title
directory description
and then walking out of these little
buttons in as well so let's add in
connect it's alright profile button
that's another one let's call this
connect button cool
alright let's actually bring this stuff
now into the card say these cool so
let's turn this into a title so let's
make it like that let's give it a name
just so we're consistent with what we've
got we're not gonna give it a name and
can I say freelancer title that's you
know what it that's let's give it a
name David Smith
it's to be in the middle that also wants
to be in the middle right let's had some
margins and things like that
here maybe shorten this cool 20 pixels
again and then we want to do is want
these to appear so free that they're
they're gonna appear in the middle
actually didn't need to do this
actually yeah I did what I should be
able to do that I think is yeah so if
you change if something's an inline
element which is basically what this
setting here does an inline element will
move will kind of adjust to the
alignment settings of its container so
in in this case the alignment settings
of the container a center so this will
it's this Alliance to Center as well if
I turn it to a block level element also
does the same thing okay obviously I
don't know I'm talking about
I dunno what I'm talking about but I'm I
know that it just sucks it's somehow
like behaves differently web play
connect cool all right so let's just
duplicate this now and again real simple
just duplicate this three column row but
we want to add some padding again so
let's call this sorry we want to add two
margin at the bottom we don't
necessarily want to add it to the three
column row so let's just try and think
about breaking things up into different
kind of containers and kind of
separating things out with with styling
so let's just call this directory block
right let's just have six sorry nine
then that's that there we go so that
didn't take any time at all to make and
that's you know it's coming together man
it's you know it's a nice prototype but
don't know why it's asked me to
translate I think it's because it's got
Laura MIPS and it's just fine okay so
this is fine but what we're lacking a
little bit here is some kind of
alignment and this whole grid system
that I've got on got going on it's not
quite right so what I think I want to do
is give this section in a right of width
of 100% right but then what I want to do
is set a max width and we can illustrate
that if we give it a ridiculously small
max width so you see it constrains to
500 pixels that's the the maximum width
that it could be but we don't want to do
that may give it like 1,200 right and
then there's there's a couple of ways
that I could I could maybe do this so I
could
think of that if I get rid of that I set
this to water that it kind of goes into
the middle there this Latin thing is
really annoying they were to translate
this sign okay but that that doesn't
really work then I guess this is this is
a broader question about the design do
we want the center column to be always
aligned in the middle of the screen or
do we want it to kind of be on the left
and then it has like a max width what
I'm gonna do is I'm gonna just I'm just
gonna have it being on the left and then
going as having like a max width and
again this is a prototype this isn't the
final finished design like if this was
the real site maybe we have like a
masonry kind of layout here so that this
this card here it would kind of fly up
and go on to the left of this card here
so you have like a sort of a Pinterest
type board thing going on but you can't
really prototype that very easily in web
flow but it still it gets the it gets
the kind of the concept across and maybe
even maybe twelve hundred it's a bit
short let's try that
they're cool so that's looking pretty
good hey what we're now gonna do is look
at how we can make it responsive and
turn it into a response approach
excuse me prototype that obviously
responds across different screen sizes
using the very kind of powerful way that
web flow allows you to build responsive
designs so let's just start a start
let's start with the dashboard okay so
this is kind of our desktop view and
that's fine but obviously when we view
it on smaller devices we want to make it
respond properly so the first thing
we're going to do is we're gonna hide
this section left this is that kind of
sidebar and we're gonna hide that and
we're gonna bring that in in just a
moment when we look at the sorry a bit
later on when we actually look at
interactions because what we're gonna do
is have a kind of a show and hide thing
so we're gonna have like a hamburger
menu up here and then we can show that
sidebar on the left when someone hits
the hamburger menu okay so we've got our
section right which we have also got a
section in Iran and that's gonna margin
so let's get rid of that margin and
let's add some padding to this so it's
not flush up against the what you call
it the sides of the container and then
we've got this kind of three column
layout which is looking a little bit
squished on tablet on on a kind of a
tablet sized screen and we've got these
two columns here as well so I mean I
don't know I think it depends on the
maybe the project and the prototype but
I mean there's two ways we could do it
we could have these stack one on top of
each other which is really easy to do a
web flow so you're just kind of choose
there that you want this to stack and I
think for this I'm gonna just I'm gonna
have that stack on top of each other
like that
these let's make the
a little bit smaller so it does break
let's maybe bring that down to like 32
or something okay and let's see how
that's gonna look on I am on a smaller
screen size there we go perfect and then
it breaks again they're just what we
want so that's cool so that now breaks
so this is what I love about web play
making responsive designs are so easy
because of the way it kind of stacks up
and just takes the existing page
structure so it's very easy just to make
simple tweak excuse me make simple
tweaks and make like a really easy
responsive experience we might also
change the line height here there's a
single line that kind of keeps
everything a bit more compact and then
what we've got here is we've got like
quite a bit big margin so let's get rid
of that notification block info block
wrapper so we've got
I said that's 20 pixels and then we also
want to get the bottom margin off this
last info box so we're gonna call this
box last again if you haven't watched
the other tutorials I suggest you do
just to kind of understand how we got to
this place and a little bit like I said
in those tutorials the point of this is
it's not really like a web flow tutorial
to show you like the exact best
practices and best ways to do things in
web flow and understand CSS it's it's
more just the process of getting like a
rough concept
interpro into web play and just building
out very simple quick prototype that
could be used for feedback and for
prototyping purposes so that's looking
pretty good
so we've got our kind of cards at the
top here and things tend to break here
and I think this is because I've got
this section as a yeah a hundred pixels
so we're going to check sorry 100 V H
which is the viewport height so we're
going to change that to Auto so it's
gonna feel to the width of whatever's in
it at 20 pixels here
the other thing we might also do it's
just add a little bit of padding here
a section wide there's something work
okay cool
so that's coming together but yeah the
other thing I thought we we might do is
just get rid of this border on here
because it's there's nothing below it so
it doesn't necessarily need a divider in
a way what's below it is the it's the
content sorry it's the the bottom of the
box so you I to last that's looking good
okay it's a bit cleaner
it's looking nice
maybe this be a bit smaller on my bow
so there so this is quite interesting
let me get to this kind of screen size
we want stuff to break and stack up on
top of one another so we're gonna have
it look like this you freelances so what
we're gonna do is just make sure that
this isn't another floated and then that
will also push those down as well so
we've got like our icon or image or
whatever it is on the job post and then
we've got you know the job title the
description cool okay let's just have a
look at how that's looking in the
browser I know there's that you can also
do it this way in web fly I just just
kind of a habit I have of viewing stuff
like this it gets to their care might
need to money to have a think about that
kirsta there and then it stacks up
rather nicely on kind of much smaller
screen sizes as well let's just take a
look at this page the the thing I was
you know when you get to this kind of
screen size it doesn't really work so
I'm gonna have another look at that in a
second let's just take a look at this
page so again I think these these are
gonna be quite cramped if there's a lot
of text or maybe long titles I think
squashing these cards up doesn't really
work that well I don't know I think that
could work
let's leave it like that so again you
know it's just just to kind of a concept
an idea that's had a bit of padding with
these guys maybe we try this full width
so that one they kind of fill up
properly so we've got our cards like
this we're kind of getting to a smaller
screen size our cards look something
like that then at this screen size they
stack on top of one another so what we
want to do is add a margin bottom to the
cards so that spaces them out and then
we want to take the margin off of the
directory block which is this stuff here
that's looking great then on smaller
screen sizes that also works perfectly
as well and we've got the dashboard h1
which is also on the dashboard h1 here
this has been inherited so this
freelancer page inherits the Styles
obviously across the board so that when
we get to the smaller screen size the
sizes of this change as well so let's
take a look at that second good take a
quick look at the login screen I think
that's broke in the container because
it's floated we can change that if we
have overflow:auto if you set Auto so if
you float something within a container
it kind of moves it out the flow of the
container so if the container doesn't
have a specific height set then it
defaults back to zero but you can change
that by setting overflow:auto I'm not
actually sure of the specific reason for
that but it's just I know that's what
works okay call login it's just me it's
a little bit smaller so we've got this
38:32 not proportion and I'll screen a
smaller screen size let's bring that
down even more not a huge amount to do
on this page and then when we get to
here
sexual wide it's set some padding on it
I thought I already did that but I did
that on something else section you know
right okay so let's get rid of the
padding on that and it's dead let's set
the padding on section wide actually no
I don't think that's gonna work okay
let's go back to
section right the reason I let the
reason that isn't gonna work is because
it's gonna push this sidebar out to the
right as well so it's just Kippur this
so we're inheriting that padding that's
great cool so let's go back to the login
screen okay let's add some padding to
this login form so that when we get onto
the smaller screen sizes it doesn't sit
flush to the right of the to the parent
unless also take out some of this
padding cool again you know it's quick
it's dirty it's just building a very
simple kind of prototype like a rapid
way of doing it just to get something
built and kind of show to be able to
show to people and communicate ideas
cool
right that's yeah this is linked up
so we can just look at our flight now so
that's goes to freelancers then the
freelancers page we have that so our
flow would be something like user lands
on the page we're gonna login email Rob
Robin Smith Kaia password whatever cool
let's login nice got our dashboard cool
let's check out the freelancer directory
simple prototype simple flow from
signing in to going to find a freelancer
so the last thing what we're going to
look at just to give it a bit of
interest is a couple of interactions so
the first thing I'm going to focus on is
the responsive navigation so we hid this
kind of sidebar navigation in the
responsive view so we're going to look
at a way to kind of bring that back and
expose that as a kind of slide-out type
menu using a hamburger menu in the
responsive you so what I'm gonna do is
just create my hamburger link um so
that's grab a div and let's call it
burger block
um let's float it to the right right
cool
let's just give it a width and a height
so we need like 50 pixels by 50 pixels
[Music]
let's just make it look like that for
the minute and what we're going to do is
just set up the interaction first then
we can just maybe look at the detail and
the design of the actual hamburger block
itself so I think what you want to do is
rather than okay so this is where I gets
interesting so we've hidden section left
maybe rather than doing that what we
wanted to is we want to position it as
elsewhere so let's just position it off
the screen right it's a minus 200 pixels
so when it gets to there it's still
there but it's off the screen
okay and let's just see if this works
in practical terms
cool so still there but it's just hidden
all right what we're gonna do is
basically use this menu block or this
button trigger to just trigger the
navigation to slide in so let's head
over to our interactions I'm just going
to use a legacy interaction for the
minute just to keep it simple and we're
just gonna call this responsive
navigation we're gonna just say our
trigger is a click so when we click on
this particular thing what we want to do
is effect a different element and the
element that we want to affect is
section left
so click element that we wanna affect is
sexually left right what we want to do
is we want to say when that is clicked
we bring we change the position of
section left by 200 pixels now it
doesn't really make sense on this view
but when we go down to this view what
you see that it makes sense right
so that should be fine
and then what we want to say is do we
want to add the next part to that so we
want to say on the second click this
moves back to its origin which is going
to move it back off the screen let's try
that that goes to there bang-bang
very cool very cool all right that's
pretty much the interaction so let's
just I'm just gonna show you how to
build a nice little hamburger menu it's
like a way that I like to do it so let's
just grab a div put it in this div and
let's just call it hamburger strip one
let's spell hamburger right right this
set width hundred-percent because it's
going to be the width of that block set
like a height of two pixels let's give
it a background as well all right just
give it like that kind of background
let's actually make this a little bit
more let's make the width let's make it
a smaller 40 by 40 okay
I'm also just gonna add a bit of margin
to that so it doesn't interfere with it
I'm also going to bring this block down
okay cool so we've got our strip one
which is like the first line I'm gonna
take this I'm gonna call it - just a
second line set it with 100% height -
pixels you know what let's go for four
pixels let's give it a background color
we can copy that okay let's give this
one
the same color let's give it height four
pixels
no let's add its ad like four pixels
between them I'm just gonna make the
last strip three same thing again with
one percent just so it takes up that
container four pixels same background
color okay pressing two am lost
cool
and then what we're gonna do is grab
that strip cool hmm so we've got if you
like you've got a hamburger block which
is like our container then within that
we've got four strips that kind of
actually represent the design of the
hamburger menu and we're just gonna move
those down and then we're gonna get rid
of this background so we've got the
strips in a container but they're not
actually and it's the container that
actually dictates the position of where
it appears just maybe make that a little
bit more about five pixels shorter cool
so and the last thing we want to do is
hide this on desktop so we'll hide that
and so when we hit a responsive you we
want it to appear there we go so we've
got
Desktop you we get down to my responsive
you click our hamburger we get a slide
out navigation and then we can keep
going all the way down awesome cool
there we have it ok so I hope that's
been useful what we've done just as a
quick recap we've taken a kind of a
wireframe concept for a dashboard for an
online freelancer platform that I just
very quickly put together and I've just
shown you how to quickly bring that into
web flow and just kind of talk to you a
little bit about how I'd approach
building it and web flow a little bit
about how I approach prototyping in web
flow and just to kind of give you a bit
of an idea of what's possible and why
it's a great tool to use so I hope you
enjoyed that again if you've got any
questions or comments leave them in the
quote in the feedback section below